Oh, hey crazies. I didn't see you there.
As you can see, I’m baking some cookies.
You know, this reminds me of something.
Where was I?
Oh right! Cookies!
If we tried to guess how they were invented,
we’d imagine some genius of food realizing
exactly what to do.
or, at the very least, someone with a lot
of time and money just randomly mixing ingredients
and setting oven temperatures until something works.
When, in reality, this beautiful creation
came to be through an insanely slow process.
First, there was just bread and crackers.
Then, in the 7th century CE, Persia discovered
sugar cane,
which quickly spread across the Middle East
and eventually Europe.
Then came cakes from the Old Norse word kaka.
Then came something kind of like a cookie
or Koekje in Dutch,
meaning “little cakes,”
which were probably originally used to test
oven temperature so bakers didn’t waste
a whole cake.
It wasn’t until 1930 that some random person
in Massachusetts ran out of nuts and, on a
whim, mixed in crumbled bits of chocolate
instead.
The point is: No single person can be credited
for the invention of the cookie.
It took a series of accidents and thousands
of people spanning many centuries
and several continents.
Discovery is almost never sudden.
It takes time.
But humans have trouble with time.
I’m not talking about time dilation
at high speeds or near black holes.
Those are actual physical changes to the passage
of time
and most of us could never hope to experience
them in any noticeable way.
No, what I’m talking about is our perception
of time,
which is deeply dependent on our biology and
psychology.
You know;
brain processing, sensory signals, amounts
of sleep, emotional states
drug use, even age!
Let’s start with the smaller issues.
We've talked about whether Planck time is a single moment in time, but that's still a matter of debate,
For a human, a psychological moment is
about 1/10 of second or 100 milliseconds,
on average.
It can vary a little throughout the day or
from day to day,
but there’s an easy way to test it with
a ruler.
Have someone hold a ruler in your hand, like
this.
Without warning you, or psyching you out,
they release the ruler.
The ruler will fall before you have chance
to catch it.
However far that is will tell you how long
it was falling.
That’s what we call your "reaction time."
For an average human on an average day, that’s
about 1/5 of a second or 200 milliseconds.
I thought you said it was 100 milliseconds.
That’s because your reaction time is 2 moments.
One for your brain to realize something is
happening
and another for your brain to do something
about it,
so half your reaction time is one psychological
moment for you.
ish.
In that 100 milliseconds, your brain can play around
with timing a little so that causality makes sense.
Like lining up what you hear and feel with
what you see.
After that, you have a limited attention span.
Transient attention is your subconscious attention
on something that suddenly changed somewhere
in your field of view.
It only lasts a few seconds.
Selective sustained attention is when you
consciously chose to focus on a task.
It can last anywhere from 5 to 20 minutes.
After that, you have to choose to refocus
on the task.
The point is: we’re hard-wired to deal well
with seconds, minutes, hours, and days.
For months and years, we need to rely on our
memory
and that can be a little tricky.
If we learn something, but it doesn’t continue
to be useful or to seem important,
your brain’s not going to hold onto it.
It’s part of why classes have assignments.
It’s why advertising gets shoved in your
face over and over and over.
Politicians use it hoping you’ll forget
their indiscretions
and their opponents do everything they can
to remind you of them.
Even when we do remember events, we don’t
always accurately remember
how long ago they occurred.
Our memory is pretty useful if you’re a
hunter-gatherer trying to avoid dangers like tigers
or poisonous plants.
But it makes us essentially blind to things
that can take decades or more,
like global warming.
Anything that seems to last longer than a
human lifespan, we call “permanent.”
Like magnets, or trees, or even cities.
When it comes to the really long-term stuff
like history, we have to tell stories.
We like there to be a narrative, for there
to be purpose.
So, when someone tells you a cookie came into
existence through a series of accidents,
it’s perfectly natural to stand there in disbelief.
It’s called "confirmation bias."
You reject the new information because it
doesn’t fit into your preexisting experience.
A single accident doesn’t appear to do much.
We can’t see its effects.
But a bunch of accidents happening over centuries?
Well, that brought us the cookie.
If a few centuries of accidents can make a
cookie, then
it shouldn’t be surprising to find 100 million
years of evolutionary accidents
turned a small mammal into a human.
It shouldn’t be that surprising, somewhere
in a vast universe, billions of years of accidents made
a solar system, where we happen to be able
to live.
These time scales are completely incomprehensible
for the human brain.
That’s why we have to rely on physical evidence
and the scientific process.
Without them, we can’t possibly hope to
see the whole picture.
Hmm, I need another cookie.
So, the next time you have a cookie,
maybe think about evolution for a moment.
Mmm, delicious, delicious evolution.
Let me know in the comments what your favorite type of cookie is.
And until next time, remember, it’s OK to
be a little crazy.
In the last video, we set the record straight
on inertia.
Comment response time!
PapaKay pointed out that I pronounced Aristotle
wrong.
Apparently, I put that emphasis on the wrong
syllable.
But if you want to get technical, Aristotle
isn’t even the full name.
It’s been shortened over time.
Technically, it’s Aristoteles.
Sounds a little more Greek, doesn’t it?
I actually include the original Greek spelling
on the HD wallpaper available as a perk on Patreon
Land Locked Viking pointed out that, without
friction, the car couldn’t have moved in
the first place.
Sure, take the fun out of it.
David suggests science isn't about “right”
or “wrong,” but about creating models.
This is important, so we’re going to spend
some time on it.
Whether we like it or not, the universe is
mostly spectrums. It's mostly grey area.
Anything you think is black or white has probably
been imposed on the world by people.
It is also true that a goal of science is
to create models so we can make accurate predictions
about reality.
Which model you choose depends on how much
error you’re comfortable with.
The Earth is pretty flat if you’re only
looking at a mile or two.
Newton’s laws work great until you go really
fast or near a black hole.
No model predicts anything perfectly,
so I would agree there is no absolute accuracy,
but that doesn’t mean you can’t be wrong.
If science were only about models and predictions,
it would be pretty boring.
Luckily, another goal of science is to see the big
picture, to get a deeper understanding.
Correct and accurate are two very different
things.
In the grand scheme, there are some absolutes.
The Earth is not flat.
It is a ball.
Period.
It might not be exactly spherical, but it’s
definitely a ball.
Those absolutes might be vague, but they’re
still absolutes
And, the more science we do, the less vague
those absolutes become.
Anyway, one more thing before we finish up:
We’re quickly approaching 10,000 subscribers
on this channel.
We’re also approaching 100 videos, but I
think we’ll hit the subscriber count first.
What should we do to celebrate?
Let me know in the comments and thanks for
watching!
Swiper clone, no swiping!
Oh man!